so we're here in the store and i'm
looking up and this is about a
i would say 2 000 square foot store yep
typical convenience size
community size and i'm seeing about
every two
about every 30 inches i'd say every
three feet
uh couple of cameras a couple of cameras
like two or three of them so the cameras
seem to be spaced out
what like in a grid of three by three
feet that's about right so this store
has 30 cameras in it
although actually we're not currently
running all 30 live uh but typically a
2000 square foot would need
about 30 cameras and these are really
small cameras what type of cameras are
there are they just standard video
cameras yeah security cameras
uh they're these are machine vision
cameras but yeah they're coming out of
the difference between a machine vision
camera and
my drop cam yeah uh really it's about
tolerances
so because we're doing a lot of what's
called multi-view geometry where we're
analyzing things from multiple
perspectives and trying to triangulate
and figure out what's happening in 3d
you really want to have some tight
tolerances on the lenses and the cameras
so that you can very precisely figure
out where something is got it whereas
with uh you know your your off-the-shelf
camera
that's more consumer-oriented this has a
plastic lens ah
the precision and tolerance of that lens
is not going to be the same as
as one of these and one of those costs
thousand bucks each or something no a
third of that probably
oh really 300 bucks yeah so you can
outfit a store for ten thousand dollars
in cameras
and a couple of servers in the back i'm
assuming ten thousand dollars in servers
so right now it's a little bit more uh
probably a store like this would be
closer to
one to two hundred thousand oh wow both
cameras and equipment the the cameras
again are gonna be the cheap part
uh but we have a lot of compute but
what's great is we're riding the
you know moore's laws dead for cpus but
it's very much
for gpus for gpus and for tpus and all
of the custom asics for deep learning
we're on this super moore's law curve at
the moment so we're we're not too
worried about the cost of the
the compute because that'll come down so
basically take a bunch of gaming cards a
bunch of nvidia cards or something in
the back
and each card can run what two cameras
three cameras
right now it's we can do two cameras on
a gpu
although we just blasted and throw a ton
of gpus at this thing seems completely
unnecessary and awesome yeah
so you're down to a level of
ridiculousness in terms of frame rate
and
understanding what's going on yes i mean
the goal is throw everything we can at
this
let's get the system working let's get
it accurate and then we'll start scaling
back the
the cost